Stannis is a killer
the Lannisters are killers
your father was a killer your brother is
a killer your sons will be killers
someday
health is built by killers what's up
ladies and gentlemen welcome back for
another Game of Thrones Season eight
update video I wasn't planning on making
a video about this but since everyone
keeps asking me about it on Twitter I
figured what the hell I might as well
give my two cents on the most recent
game of Thrones filming news this will
be a quick update video so we might as
well just jump right into it
there are a lot of new photos coming out
of Seville which is located in Spain
this is where Game of Thrones filmed
their scenes from the dragon pit during
the season 7 finale there has been a lot
of activity in this area for the past
couple days nearly all of the main cast
has arrived in this city and it's not
exactly clear what they are doing here
characters like Jon Snow and Daenerys
have not been spotted yet but almost
everyone else is here the actors have
even been taken photos with some of the
fans which makes me kind of skeptical
about this being actual spoilers since
they are coming close to wrapping up
filming further a season I have a
feeling they might be celebrating
together for one last time this will be
the very last time this cast gets
together to film a season for Game of
Thrones so I think they might be having
a big get-together because of this but I
could be wrong I'm not exactly sure how
much filming they still have to do and
they usually don't have wrap parties
until all of the filming is done
there was one photo that came out that
does make me think they are filming some
scenes while all of the actors are in
town Shawn's astark and Tyrion
Lannister's body doubles were also
spotted in the city this leads me to
believe that at the very least Shawn's
in Tyrion are scheduled to film some
scenes at the dragon pit but I am
wondering why all of the other
characters are here so far I've seen
Samwell Tarly
Gendry Arya Tyrion Sansa bran Brienne
Davos Jaime Varys and there are two
other very interesting characters on
sight this photo really piqued my
curiosity that is Jack and agar and you
have to wonder what he would be doing in
and around the dragon pit another
interesting character on this location
is the man who plays in the night Cain
could this mean jack and agar and the
night King make it to King's Landing but
I'm also very skeptical about the access
some of these actors allowed the fans to
get they almost seem too eager to take
photos with everyone around I think Dan
and Dave may have invited the entire
cast to come out and hang out because
you would think they would try a little
harder at hiding the fact that the night
King is in this location as well as Jack
and agar which is a character we haven't
seen since the NSCs
six it would be amazing if they worked
him back into the story but what could
that mean for Arya Stark would jaqen be
coming to kill her or assist her that is
the million-dollar question and if the
night King makes it this far south what
does that mean for Winterfell did the
castle fall because I don't think it
will but that's just my opinion
we did see a photo of Jon Snow and
Cersei Lannister together as they were
filming some scenes in King's Landing
but what Jon really bring his entire
family to the dragon pit it would be
taking a very big risk to bring everyone
here when they all know what Cersei is
capable of that's of course unless Jon
and Daenerys were able to take the city
from Cersei or maybe John and his family
had no choice but to lead the north
because of the night Kings advance there
are so many different options but I
don't want to speculate too much because
I have a feeling they may just be taking
a little vacation some of these actors
will film in the dragon pit but I don't
see all of them filming scenes there but
hey who knows let me know what you think
about these new developments do you
consider these to be big spoilers or are
they just hanging out and having a good
time
put your thoughts down below I want to
thank you all for watching the quick
update video I really appreciate that
and I also want to give a huge shout out
to everyone that supports my channel on
patreon have a great day
I'll see you all soon bye
[Music]
you
[Music]